the president is cheering British Prime
Minister Boris Johnson for his landslide
victory in an historic election
overnight the result allows the ruling
conservatives to finish brexit after
three and a half years of uncertainty
Johnson went to Buckingham Palace this
morning to ask Queen Elizabeth for
permission to form a new government Mark
Phillips is outside the houses of
parliament in London Marquess Johnson's
overwhelming victory expected not a
victory on this scale in the end it
wasn't even close the victory does mean
that the on-again off-again saga whether
Britain will actually leave the EU now
has an end in sight but really this is
just the end of the beginning a new dawn
rises on a new day and what a new day it
is for the victorious Boris Johnson he
had delivered a pick your adjective
thumping comprehensive devastating
complete victory he had gambled stuck to
his plan and won with a simple message
his audience knew well with this mandate
and this majority we will at last be
able to do what so Boris Johnson and his
partner Kerry Simmons returned to the
Prime Minister's residence and Downing
Street to get brexit done he now will be
able to pull Britain out of the European
Union by the end of next month as he
promised but he has a long battle ahead
of him and working out a new trade deal
with the EU and with the rest of the
world including the United States for
that matter Johnson won this election by
literally stealing his opponents lunch
taking away traditional working-class
votes from the Labour Party in Britain's
post-industrial northern Rust Belt the
same sort of disaffected blue-collar
vote that helped elect Donald Trump
Labour's leader Jeremy Corbyn who led
his party to its worst defeat in decades
says he'll quit but he won't say when
and he blamed his defeat on brexit
brexit has so polarized and divided
debaters in this country it is
overridden so much of a normal political
debate with his big majority Boris
Johnson
says he will try to bring this fractured
country together he got the country's
votes but he'll now have to earn its
trust Boris Johnson now has a lot of
political capital to spend and with the
opposition in disarray here he now has a
lot of time on his side as well
Michele Mark Phillips in London thank
you